In Update 78, we showed you the challenge
wehave with our current toilet.
- The toilet is getting quite crowded,
especially during therush hours...
This means that we would like a new toilet.
Currently, we are dropping
a bucket of poo into this hole every time...
We don't really know what to do with it.
- So, inthis video, we are gonna build another toilet,
and find a way to solve the poop problem.
Welcome to another Project Kamp update!
So, this is our current toilet!
It's a cooltoilet, but maybe it's too high for some people.
The space is quite tight...
Everything isin the middle.
This space is quite dark, and we use this lamp.
We don't have naturallight,
so without it, we would be like this:
The wood is in contact with the soil, soit rots faster.
We cannot clean our hands...
So, with only one toilet, we don't have enough for
the amount of people that we are with in the Kamp.
More people means more poop.
So, we would like to rethinkon how we can manage it.
Because, right now, we just throw it in a hole and cover it.
We would like tofind a good solution.
We need to build a new toilet!
Make a new improved design...
And also, make a newpoop system.
Let me show you what it will look like!
A new toilet design!
Let me show you theimprovements.
We have designed a deck that will go
over some concretestones.
Just so that the wood is not in touch with the ground,
and so it doesn't rot.
So, the next thing we haveadded is a sink.
That way we can clean our hands, and clean our teeth.
We can do it in a dryspace,
because we have added this roof here.
That covers all of this area!
In the back of the toilet, wehave added a window,
just so that we have natural light.
Here are the doors to take out, and put in,the poop baskets.
Because, we will continue to use those buckets,
like you've seen in our previous videos.
This box is just to store some sawdust.
Because, right now, we don't have as much
storage as we wouldlike to...
That way, the storage is next to the toilet.
Just so that the poop bucket is integrated.
Yeah! That's quite it!
Now that you guys know how it's going to be...
Let's build it, no?
Let's go!
Wedecided to do it here, which is next to
the current toilet, and next to the poop hole.
For that tobe able to start, we will have to clear the space.
And, make some new paths,
and for thatI will have the help of Ale and Robert.
Now that we have a clear space, I'm gonna level aframe.
Just so that we can fill it up withdirt,
and start with a leveled surface.
So, as you can see, we are tryingto flatten
this area with this beam.
But, it's not working, so Jaime just invented a newinstrument...
Is it working?
- Everything is working!
Let's see if it's leveled...
The area isalready cleared, and the ground is ready.
For now, we can get some stones and go get thewood!
With that, we can start building our toilet.
- Okay, so, we went to the local sawmill,
and we boughta few beams and a few planks to make the deck.
To prevent the beams to touch the ground,
wedecided to use some concreteblocks that we already had.
We have put the stones in their place.
We havealso sanded and oiled the beams, and the planks.
So, now, we justhave to build everything.
- Hello!
Hey!
We went to the Sawmillagain,
to get some planks for the deck.
With all the planks now in Basekamp, I sanded them,
and they oiled all the planks to build the deck.
To put the whole structure together, I only use screws.
I only used 80, 100, and 120 millimeter screws.
One of the problems we want to try to solve,
with the new toilet, is the height of the seat.
Right now, in the current one, it's too high...
That'sbecause of the fact that we're using standardized buckets,
and we want to keep using those.
We've decided to comehere to the back,
where the bucket will be...
Cut a space, so that we can go lower withthe seat.
Let's start cutting some wood!
Okay!
The base is done, so we went to thesawmill again...
We ordered everything at the same time,
but the saw was broken, so...
I think we went like four or five times, to get all the wood.
This time really is the last time
that we wentto the sawmill.
We got everything we need now!
So, now that I have all the materials here,
Ican start preparing everything for building it.
I got to cut the beams, cut the anglesfor the frame,
preparing thesiding, sanding everything, and route around the edges.
After a day of prepping the wood,
I got someextra help, because it was a lot of work!
Now that every piece is sanded,
they can be able to protect the wood.
But, it's toohot, so let's find another place.
- Can I help you?
Yes, please!
At this point, we have all those beams sanded and oiled!
We've seen that when you oil with a cloth,
the process takes much longer, but you use less oil.
So, now we can start assembling!
Jaime, let's go!
So, with all the pieces cut to size, sanded,and oiled,
I pre-assembled the walls.
With everything pre-assembled,
I screwedeverything together and fixed it to the deck.
We also pre-assembled the roofbefore putting it in place.
- One second! I can't reach!
Are you happy with the result today?
- I'm happy with the progress, yes!
It's looking nice!
It's looking nice...
Happy in life?
- In life?
It's not treating me bad for the last few months.
So, yeah, I could say that...
Why not?
I'm glad!
Will you be happy with a new toilet?
- Yes!
I will be happy when I don't have
to wait to take a shit.
- That sounds good!
That sounds really good!
Some video maker advice:
Don't put a GoProa mimosa to make a timelapse.
We also decided to install a little window
forthe toilet, to have a bit of natural light andventilation.
We already had these windows inBasekamp.
We recovered them from an old house that was demolished.
So, we can use these ones.
Youdon't see from outside to the inside, so that's cool!
Before starting with the siding, I'm gonnainstall a few trims,
that I made with leftoverboards.
We're gonna use some overlap over the cedar planks.
I don't really like to see the sides of the planks...
It'sgonna work as a cover of the sides.
So, it's without glue, but looking better thanexpected really!
I've cut everything with a dragsaw,
without the tablesaw, and no glue.
But, it'sstill looking okay!
I'm happy with it!
After cutting all theplanks to size,
I started putting everything together.
- So, Jaime has started with the siding.
Do you guys wanna check it out on how it looks like?
Hello Jaime!
Cool!
Whatare you doing?
- I'm measuring this offcut.
I have a corner here that I have to cut off theboard,
and yeah, I'm marking off on it.
Okay, but before Jaime finishes thetoilet...
We need to get some things.
- Where are we going Mariona?
We are going second-hand shopping!
We need some things for the toilet.
So, what we are doing now is that we are headed
to different second-handshops, to see what we find.
What do you think, Ale?
- Meh.
Okay...
- How's it going Mariona?
It's going, and we are looking at lots of things!
This fits!
What do you think?
- A bit small,but I don't know...
Maybe it's the best size?
This is a standard.
I wanted the big ones,
but I think these ones are easier to find.
- How many are we taking now?
Seven, I think.
- We areheading back to the Kamp,
after an intense day of searching for things.
So, we'll see!
We didn't find a lot ofstuff,
but we found some basic things that we need.
We found the pallets, as you can see.
I found thisbasket for the period basket.
We will use this little piece as a sink.
We found some coolhinges,
which look new, for the toilet door.
A water container, that we had here in the whitetent.
We will reuse all of this.
Let's finish the toilet!
With the leftover wood that wehad, I made a door,
and I used thehinges that we got from the second-hand shop.
The door is done! Let's continue with the siding!
I'm gonna do the plywood thingsfor the toilet!
I have my fancy drawings.
I'm screwing what Eemeli didthat
doesn't look that bad actually never mind
that
Okay, I got the box ready.
Heregoes the poopbucket, here goes the period basket,
and here goes the sawdust.
I'm gonnacontinue with the other box.
This is that, and this one is next.
Okay, I made the holes for the screws,
butthey're on the wrong side...
- They should be here on this side.
Disappointed, but notsurprised...
We are gonna build it at some point.
We need to make a hole in the wall here.
- Why?
Because, the sawdust storage is outside,
so we want to access it from the inside also.
So many options!
- Very comfortable!
Yes!
So, this is the toilet box, that Eemeli is working on.
We still have to connect this part here,
to make the full connection with the box on the outside.
This hole hereis where the piece is missing.
We need to hammer it a little bit.
We have this door, like so.
The problem now is that they don't really close...
We're going to use this thing,
and we have a similar one here, which is very nice.
And, it's red!
- You did it, Eemeli!
Can I go back tosleep now?
- Yeah, you can go back to sleep.
We also made this cool box!
We are going to use it to store sawdust.
The second precious plastic toilet seat!
When we build this toilet, we used this one.
A white and black version.
This year, we are goingfor this compliation of colors!
Pretty cool!
One for the sawdust, and one for the period basket.
There we have it!
A small mushroom handlemade out of mimosa,
with a makeshift blade, so...
To give you an overview, here, we have Basekamp.
Our current toilet is here, and the new toilet is being built right here.
Everything is going goodthere,
but making a toilet is just one part.
We also need to process all the poop that goes inthere.
And, currently, everything goes here.
We just throw it in there, with some soil on top.
It's not a verygood solution,
mainly because it smells and doesn't compost.
So, we asked our online community for
some help and input, and what would be a good way.
We got some nice suggestions, and they are going to
be the structure for it using old palettes.
The plan is to turn everything that goes inthere into compost.
But, this process will take a few months,
so we need quite some spaceto store it.
The first step: make some space.
Today, we're going to be improving theaccess
towards our poop hole system, which isover there.
So, currently there are three partsthat we are using.
However, none of them have steps,
so it's a little bit of a slipperyhazard.
The three of us are going to be working
on installing some steps right here.
And,hopefully, we can prevent a shitshow from happening...
Now that we have the steps built,
we have an easy accessto this new area.
We also have cleared this space,
where we're going to start the heap of buckets.
Right now, it's time to start assembling
the bins here in this nice clear area.
It's 32 pallets.
We got most of them for free!
We can start assembling them.
We're going to build a 12 boxes,
like 12 bins forthe compost.
Let's see how it goes!
Now, we need to get quite an amount ofhay for the poop system.
Luckily, a neighbor comes every year
to cut thegrass of our fields.
He makes travels, and uses them to feed his animals.
So, weasked him to leave some for us to use.
Now, our setup is ready to be tested!
Let'ssee how it works!
- Okay, let's film some shit!
The first step is to take the bucket away
fromthe poop compartment and put it in its place.
It's been a heavy day!
So, we put it here with the rest of the buckets.
First, we have to set up the composting bin.
We have to make like anice thick layer of hay on the bottom.
As a biological spawn, as they callit,
to hold all of the extra liquid.
So, first...
We just put it a good amount of hay at thebottom,
to around 40 to 50 centimeters at least.
So, now, it's fully covered and there's
enough hay to absorb everything.
We have the bottom ready
We have to workon the sides now.
For that, we're going to use, what they call, hay chips.
It's likethis slice of the haybale straight,
and we put it on the sides.
- Yummy...
Poo Palace!
But, what does that mean
After this first try, we realized that we need some lids,
to keep thebuckets closed and avoid the smell.
We're just gonna make some very simple wooden lids,
to keep the smelling and animals out.
So, we have our first lid!
It is held togetherby two supports on the bottom.
It fits into the bucket, which prevents it from sliding
Onthe top, we have a chamfered handle.
So, we have 11 more of these to make...
We'regonna get the team involved, and knock them out!
Okay!
So, at this point, we've finished all12 of the lids!
They've been sanded, they've been oiled,
and now they're readyto be taken to their home forever.
Let's see if they fit!
They fit!
- This is the second week into the new poopsystem.
We only have four buckets!
We open up what we have coveredlast week...
We put the new poop in...
It connects the last week's poop...
Andthen, we will cover it again, of course!
- Oh! There it is!
You're scared?
Yes! Very much!
- It doesn't look that bad!
Last one!
- We had a beat going.
What, Julie?
- I'm seeing something moving!
Yeah, that happens...
We also saw that last time.
Now that we put the poured thepoop in, we cover it again.
- It looks like it's finished, no?
Yeah!
- Ready for another week!
We covered the poop.
So, now that our poop system is running,
we cango back to the building of the toilet.
Today, I'm going to be working on the last
missing part of the toilet
We'll build a little sink area.
Last week, I saw this nice pieceof red cedar at the sawmill.
So, my idea is to cut a straight line in the back,
which isgoing to be the back of the sink.
Leave the front live edge, and then try
and cut two 45-degree-angles here and here.
To fold the two pieces.
I ran into a bit of a problemhere:
my blade isn't deep enough...
So, this is as far as it goes.
I thinkI'm going to have to flip the piece.
just finished the cuts!
pretty happy with it!
I love the book match we have right now here from the grain.
So cool!
I think it looks pretty cool!
What? A second toilet?
It's good, but let's check it with a big guy!
- It works!
Okay
So, this is the light wehave been using in the old toilet.
Inside it, there are four LED's on the frontand the back.
And, for the back one, we never use it.
So, we took it out and put it in the old light,
that we got from the yellow van.
Let's connect them!
During the building of the toilet,
I made the cable for the light connections.
To finish everything, we filled a jerrycan with water.
We filled the sawdust box.
It's nice to see that everything works!
Howmany do you think we can put in?
- Three.
Those blue buckets here?
- Four of them is just gonnabe too much,
but three of those we can fit in.
Which already helps a lot!
We inserted an awesometoilet paper holder,
made out of mimosa!
Then, we covered the area with some dirt and wood chips
So, this is the inside of the toilet!
It's lookinggood, with a lot of space.
Here we have light that Kevin did!
Here is a window for some natural
light and some ventilation.
A precious plastic seat.
Cool!
Here, we have a compartment for
toilet paper storage and a period basket.
And, here we have the storage for sawdust!
We also have Dave with us always.
Here we store all the sawdust!
This box is connected through a hole inthe wall.
It goes to the sawdust storage for the inside part of the toilet.
Here is the sink!
It'sa simple system.
We just have this water container,
which we can get some water from.
When we're finished cleaning our hands,
we can just get the water and throwit, or we can also water the plant.
The backdoor: if we open it, there is some space
for the poop bucket and we added some rails.
Just so that is easier to fit, and here,
we can storesome more toilet paper also.
But, the roof is not finished...
We want to try our experimental roof made with cans.
Here's a sample that Kevin made!
Looks awesome!
But, for that, we need more cans.
500 in total.
We will show it in another update!
Subscribe to follow!
We are also publishing the drawings of
this toilet in the research model.
You can replicate it or improve it!
And, this is our newpoop area!
Let's see how it goes in the long run.
So, the toilet is done!
I am, sorry, we are very happywith the result!
That's it for this video!
The next video is gonna be about getting some goats!
I'm joking...
It's gonna be about kitchen.
So, if you'd like to see the video now,
you can support us on Patreon!
And, if not, we'll see you next week.
Bye!